how are you Cooper I'm good rich thanks
have you bet
so how are things different this year
than last for you I think really just
having a you know comfortability in this
offense with the guys on this team
haven't returned 10 of 11 guys well
since you guys like we're kind of a
sound group together and understand each
other's games and I think that's just a
big part of it that comfortability with
the offense comes from really with the
guys and even just having you know more
snaps under my belt I think that's just
the part of the NFL you just kind of are
able to let it pick up on the speed of
the game the way that defensive schemes
are different now than they are in
college obviously and so this new pick
up on that I think is huge part of it
how thick is a playbook how thick is
yeah you know we don't have a playbook
wind around so we just roll with it what
do you mean you don't have a playbook
it's in a yeah the play books just you
know in your head you know they're not
passed around play books for us so you
know we just you know expected to learn
it and understand it and that's how we
do it yeah but yeah I mean I don't know
if you're know I I feel like I've I'm
around the periphery of the perimeter of
the area code of having you tell too
many tales out of school Cooper is that
am i picking something up here if I were
to write down our place on a playbook
yes I think it would be I think you'd
have a pretty good-sized good-sized
chapter book no I know I know you're
you're a young man and probably I don't
know if you've ever had a phone book in
this day and age in the 21st century it
would it be as thick as one as an old
school phone book I think I could make
it as thick as a phone book for you if
you d be interested in some good reading
what I am because again one last thing
here is just so how do you learn it you
you see it on you get to where the
facility and they put it on a board or
is it on an iPad for you to take home
and then not leave in the front seat
anywhere I mean how many things are
installed guys learn things definitely
but you know everything you're gonna be
installed obviously diagrams for you but
just have a you know the notes that you
take and just
standing concepts and the way that we
can adjust things and tweak things and
you know one play can turn to you know
six plays pretty quickly with just a few
tweaks here and there and so just for us
there's being able being able to be a
smart player and understand what Coach
is trying to get done and you know
allows us to kind of be able to be a
little more fluid with our plays I think
Cooper Cup Rams wide receiver here on
the Rich Eisen show did you see the
video that went viral of your coach
being able to tell exactly what down
distance play everything was from like
three four or five years ago you just
give him a down in a distance and on
against one an opponent and he off the
top of his head he remembers exactly the
play call did you see that yeah super
surprising for us guys have been around
them you know that's kind of that's kind
of normally I know he'll be telling a
story and just like oh my gosh Alyssa do
you guys and it'll just pop up the exact
play knowing the I mean he'll go
straight to the plane with the exact
time and situation and doesn't matter
how far back it was he's got a log
that's not even a lot of times it's not
even the plays that he was calling there
you know teams that he was toasting for
it could be just a random team that he
was just a game that he was washing and
we like all recall exactly what happened
come on come on really good that I think
that's the next challenge I think next
next interview needs to be no pulling up
just random games you know they'd have
to be they have to be obviously
important to them yeah in some way
although that a good play or something
but uh you know he remembers the rumors
that gets tough so what what about
anything other than football does Sean
McVeigh have a recall like that I just
in terms what yeah I'm not that I've
never seen Coast McVeigh outside of the
facility so I don't know I don't know
that he lived life outside of football
right now
oh he does they're probably not a huge
huge well I mean it could be just like
you know what'd you have for dinner
three weeks ago you know when you were
you when you were
what movie did you see when you were in
February of 2016 on Wednesday night like
that sort of thing
yeah those are the kinds of things I
think you'd have to stick to now where
did you eat me what time did you wake up
mmm - please you sleep
Cooper cup here on the Rich Eisen show
so the biggest difference between year
one to year two for you so far would be
what do you think adjustment for you
nothing yeah nothing really that's a
huge huge suggestion I think from year
one year two
like I said haven't returned so many
players staying in the same offense
hasn't been a huge adjustment just been
you know like I said before just
continuing to get more comfortable with
the guys mastering the offense and just
you know continuing to understand
coaches you know not just the concept
but really what we're trying to
accomplish with each one of them and you
see that better that they're all within
each play so that's just been any of
these differences you know not just
going out there trying to play but
running the play with with the purpose
and you know there's a couple of stories
I want to hit on you from from the
summer with you right now first one was
that there was zero preseason snaps with
everybody on a football field together
zero and and how that might manifest
itself and then there was I guess that
choppy if you will first half where you
were losing against the Raiders was that
difficult was can we draw points to a
line between what I just mentioned right
there you know I we personally being in
this office being here and being part
that game I I really don't believe that
that played a role in it you know if you
go back and I think as an offense we got
came at the halftime feeling like okay
we ran 21 plays he's like moving the
ball efficiently while we're not putting
up points I can watch you it was really
you know not finishing in the red zone
the way we wanted to and your little
things here and there can make a big
difference but we thought we're moving
the ball
well and that when we stepped on a field
that we were going to be efficient with
it and so for us I thought like coming
out of preseason we got so much good
work in practice
I'm obviously some good practices
against the Ravens there during training
camp that we felt confident heading into
that game so it wasn't often so we there
was no point for us that we felt like
all rusty or all we haven't gotten this
we haven't got it clicking it we thought
we were rolling
you know stats aren't going to show up
because you know a lot of our offense
that game that our first half came from
two big pass interference penalties and
obviously that's not your show finish
that book right and then secondly the
opponent that you had in front of you on
that monday night football the raiders
traded Khalil Mack right on the
beginning of the season rather than
paying him and it's so much of a
conversation was how that would deflate
the locker room and leave guys
scratching their heads that maybe after
a no and to start they still are in
Oakland in your locker room and your
team paid your defensive stud in Aaron
Donald and got him in and he is
therefore a to know team
what was that meat was it meaningful for
you guys how meaningful was that signing
for you guys on the outset of the season
yeah I mean I think anytime you have a
player like a D being able to get him
back here and then as a team we knew
that what incredible football player he
was and how much better we were with him
and obviously everyone on this team
wanted to see him you were pumped that
you know were able to getting back first
game and I'm moving forward here so huge
thing and you know yeah I mean yeah I
can't speak too much on you know all it
was for our defense on the ether side
well nothing over there but you know I
know those guys were prompt to have them
and obviously our defense is phenomenal
and being able to go up against those
guys every single day's a huge blessing
for us as an office okay what's more
likely Cooper Jared Goff wearing one of
the robe wide recievers gear to a press
conference like Ryan Fitzpatrick
after a win you celebrating a touchdown
jumping into the endzone like Marcus
Peters did what's more like some
receiver closers yeah that that's
definitely much more like you will not
celebrate in the manner that matters I
know I'm relieved that tomorrow I do
that okay you can grab a handful of
footballs is what you're saying okay I
could speak for you on that we're good
Cooper great chatting with you man
thanks for joining the show good luck
with you over the next couple of weeks
and before before you go I'd like to
play a game with you over the phone that
we normally do with folks here in studio
called start bench cut here on the Rich
Eisen show or I give you a choice of
three and you'd have to start one you
have to bench one you have to cut one
okay okay okay here we go
okay greatest wide receiver ever Tim
Brown Randy Moss Jerry Rice what do you
have over there
okay that you start him then who do you
bench and who do you cut yeah this is
the tough part I yeah so I'm gonna I'm
gonna bench Randy and then I'm gonna cut
10th round I mean I I feel terrible
doing
this is the cooper-hewitt now yeah
you've now entered the zone of start
bench cut on the Rich Eisen so don't
feel bad just do it just like it just
like a front office just do it and then
you move on don't worry it's gonna get
worse don't worry okay all right here's
the next one well actually maybe this
won't be this so bad most important
combine measurable for a receiver forty
forty time hand-sized vertical jump I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say 40 okay
the forty tiny started why
because I mean I'm biased what you run
it your Ford you won your 40 probably
not much faster than you you got drafted
come on you had to be sober what do you
run okay that's not that book man you'd
ballin out you see you keep proving that
4-6-3 doesn't really matter but you're
still starting it anyway okay so what do
you what do you bench and what do you
cut I'm going hand sighs bench I'm
cutting vertical okay the vertical gets
cut best thing Los Angeles has over
Yakima Washington whether food or
friends friends and quotes because you
know Los Angeles here
I'm gonna go food weather friends okay
yeah I understand that in Los Angeles
last one for you Cooper most impressive
Gruden John Jay or Sean McVeigh who does
the best McVeigh impression in your
locker room just somebody have one yet
where you're not Sean Mannion always
Sean man you does a good one yeah no
kidding yeah a rich I got you
take it easy Cooper Cup take your credit
you guys Cooper Cup a Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience